[Music]
dr. Chism will now give the address dr.
Chism president gray distinguished
members of academia citizens of the
community parents and most important of
all the graduates congratulations
graduates
and congratulations also to your three
others I'm not referring to any failing
grades I am talking about the three s
your family your friends and your
faculty here at MIT
all of whom must share much of the
credit for this great graduation day I
am honored to have been chosen to speak
here today I must admit however I was a
little bit puzzled by the invitation
because the range of my technological
expertise extends about as far as
turning on the radio and even that
venture into the world of high tech
sometimes is an act of bravery on my
part I easily can imagine a sudden
eruption of black smoke and flying
sparks
and I doubt also that my expertise in
political science has much relevance
some people go so far as to claim that
combining the words political and
science is ridiculous and impossibility
they think that political science is one
of those oxymorons those combinations
are contradictory words such as cruel
kindness or military intelligence but
whether or not political science can be
a science is beside the point I am here
I've got the microphone and I'm going to
talk and I will try not to worry that
you thought you had invited some other
shirley chisholm who may be a nuclear
physicist somewhere I would like today
to speak about the kinds of things about
which I am deeply concerned and hope
that you will be concerned also I talk
about those things because I believe
that they are important to everyone and
I talk about them because they have been
the focus of my life's work don't worry
I will also say the usual and expected
graduation day words about the
importance to each of you on this great
day and so on but first let me speak to
you for just a few moments about my
beliefs let me say why I have fought so
hard for 24 years for equality of
opportunity for people of all races and
of all backgrounds for the black women
of Brooklyn and of Roxbury for the white
women of San Francisco and Cambridge as
well as for white men and black men and
spanish-speaking men from every corner
of this country and I want to say to why
I have
it's so hard for effective generous and
compassionate action by government yes
that emotional charge word government
that has been necessary and continues to
be necessary to ensure that equality of
opportunity not rhetorically but in
actuality truly exists in America I know
that I do not have to give anyone here
within range of my voice this morning a
history lesson about equal inequality
and discrimination in our nation
everyone knows that it is not been
possible for every American to have
equal access to a decent job a nice
place to live a voice in our political
system or a chance to attend a fine
educational institution like this one
there has been inequality there still is
inequality and we need generous public
support for proven programs on
affirmative action housing education
employment legal services and on
whatever other problem areas that still
continue to raise their ugly heads but
let's talk about you as people not even
graduates not people that are going to
be acquiring some of the highest degrees
that will be offered this year in the
United States of America let's talk
about you as citizens and espouses and
as parents and members of our global
community I am NOT suggesting that you
drop everything to join the fight for
equality nor am i asking each of you to
come and in all thoughts of your
personal rewards or comforts or
achievements in your chosen
profession you do not need to march out
barefooted into the snows of winter to
combat all of the ills of this world I
am asking you to recognize and act upon
basic humanitarian responsibilities as a
citizen of course you must be an active
and informed and regular voter in
addition I hope that you make all of
your views known on public issues not
just in the voting booth but more
frequently in meetings and in letters
and by the telephone I even dare to hope
that some of you will join with me in
seeking to restore public leadership
leadership that exemplifies profiles and
courage in this great nation which is
committed to helping the needy and a
disadvantage here in the United States
of America I must say to you that fewer
events in my life have been more
difficult for me to watch than the
Reagan's administration's replacement of
compassionate egalitarian governor in
the month with government pledged to
greed and selfishness and the ascendancy
of the rich and the advantaged
in this nation and that is all that I
had better say on that subject because
once I get started it might be time to
order a pizza and settle in for a tirade
I will spare you however I am sure that
my opposition to the president's
policies is no secret to anyone here
well let's get back to you and finish
with you let me mention just a few of my
hopes for each of you as husbands as
wives
as fathers and as mothers I have been
reading that people today are beginning
once again to turn away from the cult of
narcissism to turn away from the meat to
generation and I'm so glad that it's
beginning to happen I have been
encouraged by reports of spouses who are
more committed to enduring relationships
I have been happy to hear about young
people caring just a bit more about
family and community it has been good
news that many people are accepting more
responsibility for others a kind of
responsibility which was needed to
accompany the new personal freedoms that
we gained during the past 20 years
from the easing of rigid conformity and
old stereotypes in our own homes we are
responsible for listening and for
sharing and for caring and if we have
children we have even more crucial
responsibilities to give to them the
time and attention and affection that
they need if you if we together are
truly and that is the key word truly
concerned about education and the
well-being of the next generation we are
going to have to do better as parents
the fact that schools provide only part
of a child's education the fact that
schools alone cannot teach and nurture
our youngsters is really a fact it is
not just any kind of easy excuse from
the teacher or the principal of a school
superintendent the well-rounded
education of our children is
responsibility that we cannot and we
must not sure I've talked about
responsibility and I hope that you the
graduates understand that I'm not
speaking about a depressing heavy burden
of unending obligations
I am speaking instead of the joy
producing world bettering kind of
responsibility that's less far more
burdens than it imposes I have been
trying to talk to you about a vibrant
democracy I've been trying to talk to
you about war healthy marriages I've
been trying to talk to you about happy
children and I'm talking about making a
kind of world where those children can
sit at future graduations their own and
their children's and look back at times
of greater equality greater prosperity
and unbroken years of world peace
finally you who are graduating here
today you are the foot soldiers of the
future your education has been a
complete failure if it has failed to
open your hearts to enlightenment some
of you even may become leaders in
helping to create this better world that
we all hope for thus shining the
searchlights of science into the secrets
of the universe and at the same time
holding high the torch of freedom
equality and peace each of you can help
to build a paradise on this world the
time has come and we who are skilled and
have ability can no longer sit and be
the complacent passive recipients of
whatever our education the politics of a
nation a nation is greatest the United
States of America make it free for us
but if we have live consciences and many
of you can become profiles and courage
you will stand up and be counted
you will even have the audacity to
forget conventional isms and forget
tradition when tradition is no longer
and answer to the problems that you're
groping with in this world what we will
do is to do our best deed think our best
force looking only to God whoever your
God is and to your consciences for
approval
congratulations may God guide you and
protect you and I'm looking to you to be
some of the future dynamic leaders of
the greatest country in this world the
United States of America I thank you
[Applause]